اعرب الامين العام للنيتو يانسن بيبر عن
قلقه من احتمال خروج الحرب في اوكرانيا عن
السيطره وتحولها الى حرب مباشره بين روسيا
والحلف
قال في حديث لوسائل الاعلام النرويجيه من
الحرب في اوكرانيا قد تصبح واسعه نطاق
وتتحول الى حرب كبرى مؤكدا العمل على
تفادي ذلك
وفق تعبيره
معنى
مدير تخطيط السياسات السابق في النيتو سيد
فابريس اهلا بكلام
من العام في شمال الاطلسيه
وخلقه ايضا عن احتمال توسع هذه الحرب بين
روسيا والنايتد قائم على اي معطيات
ولا فيك سبايزر
روسيا هي تشن حربا منهجه ضد اوكرانيا
وخصوصا ضد البناء التحتيه الحساسه واثر
ذلك على بعض دول الجوار مثل مولدوفا
بالاضافه الى ذلك الروسيا كذلك تقوم
بعمليه
وعمليه اخرى الحدود الاوكرانيه وصولا الى
اوروبا اوروبا بما في ذلك تخريب الانابيب
الخاصه بالطاقه لذلك فان الامين العام
لنيته هو كذلك لا يكون هناك لتوسيع
دائرتها الحرب
التي ذكرتها حدثت خلال الاشهر الماضيه منذ
بدايات هذه الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
وعلى مدار قرابه السنه الان لم يتدخل
النيته عمليا في مواجهه روسيا ما الذي
يمكن ان يح قوات النيترو ليتسع نطاق هذه
الحرب والمواجهه تصبح مباشره بين روسيا
والنيترو
جين
وكون انني عملته هناك هي تحالف دفاعي اذا
لا يسعى ولا يامل ان يكون هناك مواجهه ما
بين الطرفين هذا من جانب المساله الاخرى
يقول ما قاله منذ بدايه هذه الحرب قال ان
اي عمليه هجوم اي اعتداء على اي من الدول
الحليفه فان هذا الامر سيتم الرد بشانه
وهو فقط يعيد التاكيد وكذلك الامور التي
قالها منذ بدايت هذه المواجهه وهل برايك
تاخذ روسيا هذا بعين الاعتبار اي انها لم
تقوم بذلك لاستفزاز المباشر لدول الناتو
حتى الان
والاخير
منذ 24 من فبراير الروسيه
عن بعض العمليات الهجينه ضد بعض البنى
التحتيه التابعه لانيتو او بعض البناء
التحتيه الرقميه الروسيه امتنعت عن اي
مواجهه مباشره ضد نيت وضد حلفاء الناتو
اعتقد ان الروسيا اخذت ضد الاعتبار الخطوط
الحمراء اذن نيته عندما يضع هذه الامور
بالنظر الاعتبار يحاول ان يوضح دائما هذه
النقاب اعتقد الروسيا كانت تحاول ومنذ
البدايه بان تقوم بصياغه العمليه على انها
ليست حرب لاورانيه وانما هي مواجهه مع
الغربه لكن الامر ليس كذلك في واقع الامر
فابريس
السياسات السابق
شكرا جزيلا لك